I know there must be many thoughts
going through your mind right now.
Is this the right place for me?
Do I belong here?
Well, let me assure you
that we see something in you.
Something you may not even see yourself.
Even if you do have X-ray vision.
Congratulations
and welcome to Godolkin University.
You know, Golden Boy plays on his poster,
not making me out.
It's like a big, fiery sea cucumber.
Golden boy.
Jordan. Andre.
They're going all the way.
They could save thousands of people.
What's coming up with your superior
name on here?
Bloody Mary.
That's terrible.
Okay. Coca-Cola. Even worse.
Okay.
I'm not going back in it choice.
This is weird.
You're coming on.
Who else have you told?
Nobody. Don't say another word about this.
What's going on?
It's like
there are evil people at this school.
This is way bigger than us.
We need to make this right.
It's your shot at real power.
Remember, no tiny action hero
Get it? Got it. Good state. Jesus.
Digging for the truth is a rush.
This is just a tiny bit.
isn't it?
Don't answer that.
It's rhetorical.
It's just a matter of time
before everything else.
If the woods is exposed, we'll have a big,
potentially fatal problem.
It's like South. up.
I'm up.
one thing that is really apparent now
is that we are all up.
It's like.
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. This will be my new boys
Gen V Trailer
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references.
They confirmed
they're doing Tek Knight from the comics
and a bunch of other characters,
like Soldier Boy, played by Jensen.
Ackles is coming back,
so we'll explain what's going on.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do videos for
the episodes is dropping later this month.
We'll explain the schedule
later in the video.
This time they begin the trailer
with Clancy Brown's character
and he's playing a professor
parody named Richard Brinkerhoff.
and within the universe of the boys, he's
just pretending like his front
is that he's a professor of crime
fighting at this university.
But the whole idea is that
the university is a front for Vought
to find more compound these superheroes
that they can use to make more money off
of even though Godolkin university
isn't from the comics, they're doing
a bit of an X-Men parody here.
There is an X-Men parody in the comic book
version of the Boys.
They're called the G-men Team, led by
an evil version of Professor X, basically.
Clancy Brown's professor
X type of character does have Compound
V's superpowers.
They didn't say exactly what they are.
But if he's meant to be a Professor
X parody,
then they might be mental abilities.
but basically the idea with the spinoff
here is they
have this university
called Godolkin university God U,
which is meant to be a VOC
controlled school
that they used to pick through
all the compound bee babies
to find one that they can actually use to
make more money off of they're building.
The show is a little bit like X-Men,
like Xavier's School for gifted youngsters
in the Boys, Universal, X-Men in the Boys
universe, mixed with The Hunger Games
as they're all fighting for a chance
to join
the Seven in the whole Hunger
Games thing is the idea
that they're basically
killing each other off.
last person standing
gets a chance to join the seven.
the hoity in the boys universe is that
with very few exceptions across history,
parents will submit their children
for compound B testing
because at least
at the present day compound
the only really worked on children
when adults would take it,
it would just wind up making them explode.
recently.
They changed that
with the temporary compound.
B Like now
you see adults being able to take it
and it's a slightly different form
of the compound.
B but all the older children
and all the adults
who would have taken it
with the exception of Ryan and Homelander,
were basically dosed with compound B when
they were children as part of experiments
just to become part of
what's testing, to see if they could make
a better version of the formula
or if they could make a superhero
that they can make a ton of money off of
that was the real reason.
Like, hey, you submit your child,
you have a chance
to earn a lot of money off of them.
They could become
really rich as a superhero,
but really they just wanted them
as cannon fodder for their testing.
if they wound up developing really cool
or really marketable
useful superpowers,
that was just a bonus side effect.
the reason why Homelander was an
exception is because he was actually
artificially created in a lab
they took genetic material
from Soldier Boy and tried to refine
his DNA to make an even more powerful
superhero in that became homelander.
there is that across history.
You have all these different people
secretly submitting their children
for testing to get compounded
when they're babies.
well why ends up happening
is that a lot of them don't develop
any kind of useful superpowers
or they have really weak superpowers
that BART doesn't really care about,
or they just wind up being failures
they're either cast aside
or the parents can't deal with them
because their powers are
too out of control or they're too powerful
they would get sent to places
like Red River Institute,
which are basically
like all the compound babies
that nobody could control
that's actually where one of the main
characters comes from here.
Marie Morrow it looks like her
power is blood manipulation, veins,
arteries manipulation
and a regenerative healing factor
talking about Marvel, DC references,
like all the characters are meant to be
comic book
references or parodies in some way,
she'd be a little bit more like Carnage
from the Marvel Universe based on the way
he uses his powers differently from Venom
and the other Symbiotes.
you could also make an avatar, The Last
Airbender blood bending reference to
And they're actually doing a Netflix
live action avatar,
The Last Airbender,
which I'll be doing videos for.
I've already done
a trailer video for that,
so I'll post a link down the description
below.
the idea with Tek Knight
is he's being played by Derek Wilson here
you see him in the trailer briefly.
It's like a short scene where he talks
about the rush, quote unquote,
I was hoping that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
would wind up being their Tek Knight.
But he's actually playing a totally
different character during season four.
within the world of the comics.
He's meant to be a parody of both Marvel's
Iron Man and DC's Batman.
But the showrunner said,
for the purposes of the show
versus the comics,
they lean more in a Batman direction.
On the TV show.
something about them feeling
like Batman was more ripe for parody
than Iron Man's character,
even though they're both pretty ripe
for parody.
the whole idea with Batman and Iron Man,
they're similar in the both billionaires
that use their technology
to make themselves superheroes,
a bunch of gadgets, a bunch of armor,
instead of having natural compound
V abilities, like other superheroes
in the boys universe like Homelander
He's a huge character in the comics,
but he's super funny in a very,
very disturbing, messed up way.
Tek Knight as in technology like Iron Man,
Take Night has no natural powers.
All of his abilities come from the gear
that he invents, just like Iron Man
in night, as in The Dark Knight.
And in the past, he had a sidekick
named Lady who was a version of Robin
who also left him when he got older
to become a version of Nightwing
that they call Swing Wing on the series.
just like Iron Man and Batman.
He's super rich and has his own Batcave
full of weapons and machines that he uses.
This is a clip from season one
where they're actually
talking about the tech Knight character
during the superhero partners
support group for people that were injured
while they were getting
busy with superheroes.
there was also a separate technic clip
of the DB doing a commercial, talking
about making things more eco friendly
and referencing that he made Tech Knight
make his Batmobile
more eco friendly.
It's funny and messed up is all
that was like.
It gets even worse as that scene
goes on the way we're actually introduced
to the Tech Knight character
for the first time in the actual story
was way crazier.
He's in a therapy session
right at the beginning of volume two
because he has a compulsive addiction
to getting down
with anything that he lays his eyes
on, even inanimate objects.
And it was because of that problem
that he was kicked out of one of the other
major new superhero groups called Payback.
That's a group
that's led by Stormfront, also
one of the new characters
during season two.
They go on a mission to take down
this hostile army in a foreign territory.
But as they're
flying back to their headquarters,
he starts to stare at his teammates.
But it just can't stop thinking about it.
He winds up trying to get with him
mid-flight in the air
and everybody freaks out.
Stormfront in the others immediately
kick him out of the payback team.
Remember way back during episode one
when Starlight was named
as the new member of the Seven.
It was a big deal originally
that was supposed to be Tek Knight.
He was going to become a member
of the seven,
But Vought American found out
about his little quote unquote problem
in vetoed his membership on the spot.
like I said,
Jensen Ackles Soldier Boy is coming back.
But they didn't say what he's going to be
doing during the series
and how he comes back
if he's still meant to be in that deep
freeze prison where they have him in Cryo
kind of locked up,
so to speak, for all time.
or if it's some sort of flashback
or some sort of training footage
that they use or footage that he filmed,
kind of like those funny Captain America
ads that they did during Spider-Man
homecoming that they were forced to watch.
They made Steve Rogers film when he was on
DOD and became part of The Avengers.
Like, you know,
why don't you do this for the government,
film a bunch of these tutorials
for these kids.
Read it to the Boys Season three ended.
Jensen Ackles did say he could come back,
but that has to be kind of twisty
about the way they brought him back.
I think he was just referring to them
putting him on ice, so to speak
there are a bunch more crossover
characters from the Boys Season four
that will star during this.
They did say that it would directly set up
the boys season four.
I think that has a lot to do
with the Victoria Neuman footage
during the trailer
and them seeing the whole idea that she's
trying to take over the White House.
in at least
before the events of last season,
she was working with Stan Edgar
and it was all part of its grand play
to take over the White House
so they could influence public policy,
including real power,
basically take over the government slowly.
then she called an audible
and kind of went her own way with it.
But she's still technically kind of
on the side of Vought,
even though she's very self-interested,
victory.
Neuman is based on Vic
the Veep from the comics.
It was a male character in the comics,
but the whole idea is that he becomes
the vice president of the United States.
So it sounds like they're headed
in the same direction with boys.
Season four.
the whole difference, though, is that
by the time they actually get the story
into the White House, like by the time
the boys characters are in and around
the White House, it's
almost the end of the comic book story.
And they made it sound like the show
could go way beyond that,
like it'll go more than five seasons,
but we'll see about that.
these new Gen V episodes are meant to take
place between the events of the boys.
Season three in season four, though,
There's this place
they keep referring to as the woods.
Like the characters are yelling,
I'm not going back to the woods
like it's some terrible place
where they get experimented on.
if we're talking about an X-Men
parody here, that might be their version
of the Danger Room.
but it's just a place where
VOUGHT Scientists experiment on them
they're supposed to drop
the first three episodes on the first day
and then it's weekly after that.
But it'll be eight episodes
like the regular Boys season.
So I'll do more videos
when we get a little bit closer
to the point,
release a little bit more footage
if there's any more Easter eggs
or references
that you spotted in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
There's a bunch of big stuff
coming up to my Ahsoka Episode
5 video we'll post next week
As soon as they release it. Click here for that,
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that. And click here
for all my other Boys trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
See you guys in the next one!